what are some things about you if you
had to change something honestly had to
change something about crystal you're
like oh this has to go counting our calf
power I would have calf power yeah yeah
yeah no I have no calf our oh my god I
don't have power in need you don't have
any no dude if I even look up for a hi
book on a shelf a [ __ ] you're sorry
right you got to get a water dude dude I
have no calf power and I love working
out and when it comes to calf I just I
guess I just go you know what [ __ ] I
guess forget it do it you just leave at
the end oh yeah I don't I don't I save
them for the end and then I don't do
them yeah yeah yeah and the workout
early dude my mom my mom would always be
like when I was a kid she would this is
the same kind of [ __ ] she would be like
what kind of homework do you have and I
would be like oh I got English I got
math I got [ __ ] social studies I got
this and she'd be like okay cool and
then like three and then like five
o'clock would roll around be like you
should get started on your homework I'd
be like you know what I [ __ ] talked
to Mike the math thing isn't due until
[ __ ] Tuesday so I don't have to do
that tonight and then turns out social
studies was a lot less than I thought it
was and she'd be like oh really I mean
like yeah okay and then nine o'clock and
she was like dude you your homework I'd
be like no but it's actually okay if
you'd be like what and I just would
never do my that's what that's what calf
exercises is like I would never do dude
I [ __ ] wish I'll tell you what man
[ __ ] dude I'll tell you what I wish you
know how they always say like kids do
your homework stay in school I wish I
didn't do more homework I wish I did
less homework really yeah dude we do
dick jokes yeah oh yeah I don't know
about working imaginary numbers I don't
have to do any of that work but I when I
did math okay when I was in math and I
was not doing well in math where did you
sit in the classroom oh the back until
they made me so he made me sit in the
fall that were like yeah that was always
exactly through like you thought the
back was the worst until you got to the
front it was like they lapped you with
the front yeah you could sit in the
front end like oh the back is this year
and they're like nah I'll get back in
the front like these [ __ ] I'm
lapping these people that's how about I
am so it then didn't all your friends in
the back look so dumb then once you got
to the front oh they did and yeah and
they you were even dumber but they could
only see your back
they can see your face yes so I so I
would do math and then and then I got
like to him at like we got two imaginary
numbers and I was like if you're just
gonna make this [ __ ] up and now on I'll
fail [ __ ] you know what I mean like
[ __ ] go [ __ ] you where's the camera
go [ __ ] yourself with your imaginary
numbers yeah and that's common core man
when I was growing up they had yeah it
got all kind of crazy carry the one I'm
like all this [ __ ] it sounds like a fire
hazard like things got real vague and
things were
it sounded like somebody's getting
abducted remember that mmm carry the one
I'm like I'm out of here yeah I'm not
into that
yeah I'm like in my I go I go did you I
go single digits and if you want I could
go a little bit of double digits and
then that's it then you get into
hundreds and Karie and [ __ ] and ex
exponents right before kind of here I'm
not here scientist yeah yeah what am i a
[ __ ] burn victim do you think I want
to know how all these chemicals well I'm
just like dude you want me to do this
I'm like Chernobyl exploded anyway and I
don't have anything like you got guys
who do that [ __ ] me if [ __ ] out of here
that's true what are we gonna do with
that information man do you remember
learning about how like a neighborhood
worked remember that where the postman
should go in the neighborhood it was
effective so we yeah so we never learned
that my town we never learned that and I
don't think that that's a class but you
you may be may you may be learn that
that would be amazing if there was a
class on how a neighborhood work you
know what dude there should be a [ __ ]
class on how because there's the thing
there should be these are these should
be the classes okay for real okay I'll
get out English a little bit up to like
fourth grade yeah and then high school
knowing you don't need a English in high
school you don't need English in high
school yeah if your here's the thing if
you're don't know English how you even
get these you're in eighth grade and you
don't know how to talk you have to you
have to join the army
right cuz like you know and your front
line you understand you're not the guy
in the back by the way army that's how
the class yeah it's obviously yeah
you're dumb as [ __ ] you're in the front
you know they're all the lap to
[ __ ] impose oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're the catch both with your
heart yeah exactly we're a head head or
heart johnny caught it in the shoulder
he's not good enough not good enough
so okay so that's two of the classes is
that English is out right
social studies by the way that's what we
learned about the neighborhood what is
it yeah but but it's not though do you
understand it's neighborhood statues all
right right right right
so this is what you should be actually
for real how a city or neighborhood
works okay okay that should be class and
we call that what just basically Street
beats all right I like that it's a good
class name also if the class names were
hip yeah
if the class names were hip like that I
would be in it man yes sir I take Street
beats doing Street beats a PAP Street be
hey Larry got a tattoo huh huh now why
did Larry get a tattoo right yeah so
today we're learning class why Larry got
a tattoo and I'm in the I'm in the front
right
is it cuz his name is Larry all guys
name let her have a tattoo if you ever
met a guy who's named Larry it doesn't
have a tattoo and he's not in the Three
Stooges
you haven't met Larry I'll tell you that
much so so so you got streets in those
three beats swimming huh mm depends
really not not in Indiana right all but
in LA yes in the west coast East Coast
you know being a beach guy yeah
um maybe like up near you know some some
[ __ ] city west of Portland
you might learn that body style or like
yeah you learn you know what you you
know what's a good what a good class
would be like to learn who an alpha is
like you have to understand who the
alphas are and we call the class Peck
the pecking order okay yeah an order
like you don't yeah okay yeah I would
who you who do you have for P uh yeah
yeah and it would be like this real
[ __ ] either you would have teachers
that were like real alpha or these real
beta [ __ ] that were like look I
understand who I am
and it's okay if this is who you are but
you need to know who you are and if I
doubtful walks in the room you kind of
look at them like you know I mean yeah
that's water the plants oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah you look at how you offer him
a lollipop or whatever the [ __ ] it is
like ooh you know you understand you
know now class right pecking order it
would be like Greg stand up show us how
you look at an alpha and it'd be like
because I'm a beta
yes and then Greg goes like this and
you're like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just keep
hanging the Christmas ornaments Greg
right he'll be over there another
mistletoe he'll be over there under the
mistletoe hundred percent yeah yeah I
think how to behave that functions is
another one good one function behavior
that could probably be in pee oh yeah it
could be BNP oh yeah it could be like a
coz alpha second tier yeah cos alphas
behave differently than betas and oh
it's different you know alphas will
leave the place early I'm kind of go to
something better than that don't blame
me think and get there later
alphas are on the in places for like 25
minutes yeah so they barely missed off
they get there late and they left early
yeah would you say you're an alpha me
yeah no I think I'm more uh more of a
beta really I'm like one of this Chinese
fighting fish I think what are those
betas yeah but I think they have their
own alpha beta [ __ ] going on well I mean
yeah they're suicidal some of them you
know but they only think they're killing
them so I don't think it's a mirror in
the kiln themselves that's why they do
that
that's so [ __ ] interesting you know
what you came to a dinner once and you
came late and left early remember that
didn't really I didn't know you might be
an alpha yeah because you guys at first
of all was the dinner in the dark oh
well that's what a [ __ ] that's what a
nice place oh you don't go to offer come
bright place for dinner do it what are
you [ __ ] you know you made some money
you gotta go for him dim the lights
yeah I want to see what nah dude that's
right you're poor in your heart you're
poor in your heart you got let that go
it's true man you are poor in your heart
you're not really okay but but that's
okay that's why people like you bro
that's one of the reasons why people
like you I like you is one reason why I
like you yeah yeah who are very
different but we also like we vibe off
each other and I'll tell you - what was
I gonna say um oh yeah you thought you'd
be all alpha by coming late and leaving
early yeah I paid for your meal meal so
you're not gonna out alpha me bro yeah I
was like what am I gonna do and I took
what we should have learned in school
and I was like it was like that meme
with the [ __ ] who's the guy yes that
guy Phonak is doing all the math and I
was like pay for it bye bye I got it
I'll pay for and they all went oh they
did the wee babies that's a pecking
order yeah
duder you start to live through memes
you think I don't know I did - memes
Oaks and I think that's probably yeah
that's probably it for the day probably
yeah I thought about that when I said I
was like huh
too many memes jobs but
well thanks for watching that video
right there that was a beautiful little
segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe subscribe